[Music]
welcome all right and we are live i'll
or podcast lords gave it that that I am
dork a Dido and we have two fine
gentlemen in the realm this amazing game
for triumph so what are these two
gentlemen that we're talking to right
now
so Madam's are my key marketing manager
of the game okay and yourselves I'm
telling I'm the writer of the game and
the social media awesome and very
quickly tell us about for triumph what
type of game it is or its turn-based
tactics with first edit strategic
overlay Sam I describe it as a mixture
over XCOM and Heroes of Might and Magic
you said ex-cons
we are fans of XCOM we like XCOM the
battles should be fairest female
familiar to whoever played a store
before but we have a big difference the
environment is interactive you can
topple to use it enemies you can push
boulders at them and they can do the
same to you awesome enough talking let's
see this game eh let's get into let's
get into this game I'm excited
all right so he getting it started up
right now and again now as far as what
full we get started I just want to get
some basics out the way as far as what
engine are you using for this game you
know cuz it really looks very colorful
with nice art style very vibrant what
engine are using we actually it's a
custom engine we actually a beautiful
statue wow custom okay it took her about
four years to make it
Wow yeah the first two years it was a
hobby project and then it's out of hold
on from them or sub awesome as you can
see Mattel is using the environment to
actually attack the enemies it's gonna
kick the tree and just make it topple
over the enemy
Wow so this is the destructible
environment okay nice okay this is also
again a lot are there specific specific
things in the in the map that can be
used to hurt the enemy so that cover is
actually can be used as a weapon exactly
okay actually almost anything can be
used even the enemies themselves can be
phone at each other Wow advanced enemies
will do the same to you so yeah as you
can see yes so I'm checking it out right
now cancel reaction oh they got they got
him cornered now do we I've noticing
that forest party makeup and then
abilities let's talk about that so how
many people are in your party and for
all we got some nice cinematic action up
close I like this now how many people
are your party and then as far as
abilities are there different archetypes
of characters yeah so you have installed
in full heels in your party you can
actually extend your party later on
these are pretty basic you have abelian
and
paladin imogen Ranger they all have
different abilities and as they going
level they gain more special abilities
or they can power up till old abilities
now they aren't that what you say a back
and I don't I see skill tree yes so
there is a full skill tree that did okay
nice Wow so you can actually level
things up you can actually see what they
would become if you level them out you
also get special abilities that you have
to get experience to get them and then
it's kind of randomized you don't know
what you're gonna get you get a choice
of clay nice time nice also between we
have what we call cost class abilities
so you sometimes gets at one of those
internet in my school and so even
characters of the same class can often
turn out quite different from each other
so that's where that orangie that
randomization comes in so that nothing
no two characters are necessarily always
exactly the same now you say right now I
got four characters there now you said
you get more now you get more added to a
party or just only four at a time so you
can get both you can have several
parties I know you can just extend your
own party it really depends on how you
develop the game because you also have a
city which you can develop you can build
a
more buildings at your fault you can
expand your abilities there and then it
decides on how you're gonna play the
game with more parties or just one large
body Wow so you okay again just for
clarity you can have two separate
parties or even a or even three all at
one time
yep so what's the max player account max
per account you have before entire map
the world for ways people that you can
control over man okay oh wait and I'll
face parties by party on the twenty you
could control twenty people that think
so
Wow Wow several cities as well now say
cities explain that whole concept by you
you're building communities explain this
whole city fix so you have a town but
else you might want to visit the town
and show it to us here you can build
plots of land and below update old
buildings as well the building
simulation going on this is a just
turn-based action we're actually
building things as well yeah that's yes
did you play of the game and really
affects the gameplay because the things
you gain from that it's just just a
bonus for attack or defense it's as
you've said
hills or maybe more action points or
maybe more inventory slots so we think
it's a demand and overlay that really
moves the tactical aspect of the game as
well I'm loving this aspect this is a
definite surprise now let's talk story
and story beats this this is a so this
is the way that you'd end up getting
more characters into your party right so
you look your resources and things like
that to build up your town so let's get
em from cages or from other enemies and
then gain them without getting the
improvements okay so that several kinds
of voice to get more characters you
could also the servos several mini
quests on the game where you can you
have multiple choice between different
text okay and then the results also
depends on on the Tate's you have okay
then you could get more characters so is
there like a character creation let's
say cuz I know where I'm coming from
like I have a lot of streamers I'd like
you know a lot of my subscribers so that
when I'm playing they were like I want
to be invested I want to be part of this
game so do you have the option so I can
change names put people into the game
character creation change names they can
change the colors of the characters but
further customization is actually right
now at least impossible
yep awesome now back what is a focus
back on our story beats all right again
like how are you guys
handling the narrative of the game and
as far as like what's the overall story
here in Fort triumph so this is not a
story mode but in the stonyold with
react
it's kind of an it looks like classical
fantasy but it's actually a parody the
entire thing is for example the peasants
always seem preoccupied with what the
nobles are doing and the novel's know
that they can sort of they never
actually fight each other but I always
pretend to be fighting so the peasants
who stay preoccupied and we try to take
it into a more quickie really kind of
humor spirit the cartoonish style we
feel it's better influenced by Terry
Pratchett and Discworld if you know yeah
absolutely
so that's the direction we took it to
anyway so while it seems like a cliche
fantasy we actually took it to a more
funny place nice that's a look low
whimsical not as serious you know is
that okay that's cool there's a
different take on it which I like so I'm
definitely loving that aspect the next
question I have for you is if it's a
sometimes games like this support or
multiplayer model is something that you
would ever consider you don't say
there's something that you would ever do
in the future
it's already done actually all in this
game good
I've a eye or actual players you have
choices you can have much larger maps in
this Wow so we are doing motor playing
for a trial
awesome that's a basin go that's awesome
what I'm really liking is the fat you
know you can actually use your own like
friends and characters discover because
if you're looking as the running past
you'll see little shields like you know
your guys and your friends can actually
cover for you which is actually nice
because the many collectors have an
attack of opportunity you can actually
place them before your mages and the
enemy will try to 1/2 because you I want
you but if they come too close they will
attack one way you can actually create
the formation this is pretty awesome now
as far as any big tax I know you say one
thing you said the enemies could kind of
do what you can do also now do you have
more powerful enemies maybe bosses
anything in that nature where you fight
really soft where enemies where you got
to kind of bear down on these enemies
yeah so you have many bosses and bosses
nice it's a high high Italian level yeah
enemies also you have other character
opponents them enemies can actually do
what you can do and get the resources
and actually take things that you want
for yourself so both kinds exist enemy
heroes and and impulses this is awesome
so again last question as far as on that
the type of game modes you said multi
player you said story mode so is there
another MOBA sighs those two although
those are your two basic the basic story
and then the multi player is actually
the okay skirmishes the bolts are fine
yesterday mode officially awesome and
how far we develop it right now it's
actually almost done it's gonna come out
this year and it's early access on Steam
it's been a while and we put it up but
it's getting quite far along with this
polishing it up we're trying to gain
again as much feedback as we can and
just polish anything up but it's almost
done oh wow this is hype i'm super hyped
for this they're our last question wanna
say is i know you stood steam but as a
console guy i would love to see this
come to console and as a colorful art
style guy i love the series company
Nintendo smash
are there any plans that these might
happen or cause our plans
it's more than likely more than likely
sounds good to me
listen your board triumphs very
surprising title a little hidden gem
we're gonna keep our eye on it absolute
pleasure to cover this game we are
looking forward to the present have you
in a realm
thanks for triumph island or podcast
abroad be able to look out y'all
[Music]